- You have done "SNL",
Broadway, so many things,
but is it true that your
greatest achievement
is bargain hunting?
One of my friends is great at this.
Are you really great at this?
I'm not good at this.
- You're not?
- No.
And I grew up with no money, I just...
- What about your Wayfair plug?
- Well, here's my thing. No.
(audience laughs)
I'm not good at bargaining,
like in this sense
of like going out and getting something.
- Okay.
- I'm good at getting you
bargains, you're welcome.
- But I'm not good at like going out
or like if you go to like a flea market
and people are like, oh
you can like talk 'em down,
like I'm, mm.
- I'm not good at that either
'cause I get shy and embarrassed
and I don't want people
to think I'm cheap.
- Yeah, yeah. I guess, yeah.
- So I panic on that for sure.
Like, I'll pick up the
whole bill at dinner
instead of like argue over
how many Cokes somebody had.
- [Kelly] 100%.
- Okay, that's fine.
- Yes.
- But I get a lot of like,
dopamine hits from being thrifty.
Like, so, if I find something cheap.
Or if I find, like I paid
for all of our flights
to Europe using points and miles.
So, and it was like the
scene from "Homeland"
or like "A Beautiful Mind",
like I was like swapping,
like I can move the Hilton
over to American points.
And my husband's like,
"Literally you could
be doing anything else
and making money right now."
But anyway, but I get really,
like the thrill of it's amazing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the thrill of the hunt is great.
Like finding something and getting a steal
and that makes me really excited.
- Okay, so I get this,
my sister once told me,
I had no idea, right.
So I was like an Amazon
Prime member or whatever.
And I don't work for them,
so this isn't like a plug.
I just mean I didn't
know and I was, you know,
paying for birthday parties
and paying for things,
like things that you get for things,
just constantly, right?
- Yes, yes.
- And 'cause I'm a working
mom, single, whatever.
My sister was like, Hey, by
the way, did you realize.
I had, this is not a joke, like six mil,
it was like some crazy 6 million points
or something because I used my-
- Amex
- Some...Amex?
Yeah, card or something.
And I was like, "What do you mean?"
So then I proceeded to shop
for like two years for free.
- That's incredible.
- On Amazon.
And I was like, "What?"
(audience claps and cheers)
And every time I'd say, use
my points and it goes zero,
it doesn't matter how much
money you have in life,
it feels good.
- Oh, it feels great.
So here's the best one I ever did.
Okay, so we have a house on Fire Island,
which is like a little beach community.
- [Kelly] I've heard of Fire Island, yeah.
- It's a barrier reef island
off the coast of Long Island.
Anyway, a lot of rich people
throw away their stuff
at the beginning of the season,
which makes for really
great bargain hunting,
'cause they'll clean out the house
'cause they're preparing
to rent their house
or whatever, so it's-
- What about those garage sales?
- That's I'm saying, they
don't have a garage sale.
They just put it on their, like,
those like little trash,
you know, box things
to keep the deer from eating your trash.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
- Yeah, yeah, that you
keep for bears or whatever.
- Yes, exactly.
So they put their stuff out.
So one time I, one
weekend I was walking by
and there was a perfectly
good Nespresso machine.
I already had a Nespresso machine
which I had gotten for my birthday,
but a month later
there was a perfectly
good Nespresso machine.
It looked brand new.
I took it home, I was super excited.
I poured water through it.
It poured straight out the
bottom and all over my floor.
Okay.
- Oh.
- Under-
- You see why it was-
- Got it.
- Got it, yeah.
But you know what I did?
I was like, "This thing looks new."
So I picked up the phone
and I called Nespresso
and they're like, "Oh yeah,
that serial number is new.
I'll send you a new one."
Completely new.
So I gave it to my friend
Sally for her 40th birthday.
- Look at that.
- Because, yes.
(audience claps)
And the greatest thing
is she's also thrifty.
So I told her the whole story.
She was like so extra excited
that it was trash picked.
- Yes, that's thoughtful.
- She trash picked a solar
once in Brooklyn, so yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
- Friendship.
- Yeah.